Des chercheurs de l'université américaine de Harvard ont trouvé un traitement efficace contre la COVID.
Selon le professeur Paul McFalse, l'acidité naturelle du vinaigre permettrait de lutter rapidement
contre les infections des voies respiratoires.
C'est bizarre, non ?
Ça sent la fake news.
Il faut que je consulte un expert.
Ouais, si tu veux mon avis, ça me parait
gros comme une maison cette histoire.
En tout cas, gros comme mon atelier.
Comment se fait-on piéger ? Comment ces fausses informations se propagent aussi vite ?
On décrypte tout ça dans ma nouvelle vidéo "Chez Jamy" avec Hugo.
C'est bien moi, t'inquiète pas, on est bon.
Alors, Go Hugo.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de cette info à propos du COVID,
un traitement à base de vinaigre ?
Apparemment, ça viendrait des États Unis. Des chercheurs américains, franchement, ça sent la fake news.
Ouais, j'ai vu passer ça aussi, cette info sur les réseaux sociaux, d'ailleurs je crois qu'elle a des centaines de milliers de partages.
On parle d'info, on devrait plutôt parler d'"infox".
C'est le terme officiel dans le dictionnaire français.
Pour désigner comme ça ces nouvelles mensongères qui sont construites de toutes pièces exprès, pour tromper le public.
Enfin, bon fake news, infox,
Il y a plusieurs termes, mais ça veut dire donc la même chose.
Et contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait imaginer, cette technique de désinformation ne date pas d'hier.
Allez, je vais citer quelques exemples.
Au VIe siècle, l'historien Procope de Césarée,
rédige un ouvrage contenant de nombreuses informations
très douteuses sur l'empereur de l'époque Justinien.
Objectif : nuire à cet empereur.
Un autre exemple : au XVIe siècle.un polémiste du nom de Pierre l'Arétin,
lui, ne s'est pas gêné pour utiliser les fake news
afin de peser sur l'élection du pape de l'époque. Il a composé des sonnets, des poèmes plein de rumeurs et de calomnies
sur les différents candidats.
Et lui, il est allé plus loin puisqu'il a collé ses poèmes
sur une statue de Rome pour que
ces fausses informations se répandent.
Une petite dernière pour la route ?
Allez, on part en Angleterre au XVIIIe siècle,
au Royaume-Uni,
les fausses nouvelles sont presque un sport national.
Il existe même des "paragraph men".
Alors, ces personnes sont chargés d'écrire de petits paragraphes qui ne font en général que relayer les rumeurs et les ragots,
comme par exemple sur les supposées infidélités
de Marie-Antoinette, la reine de France de l'époque.
Et le point commun avec les fake news d'aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on peut retrouver,
c'est l'objectif, qui est le même : tromper volontairement
les gens. Hier comme aujourd'hui,
on utilise donc les fake news pour nuire à d'autres,
pour acquérir, conserver, renforcer son pouvoir, une notoriété,
s'enrichir ou même favoriser un groupe d'intérêt.
La fake news peut donc d'ailleurs rapporter beaucoup au final.
Et le pire dans tout ça, c'est que plusieurs études
ont montré que les fausses informations
se propagent beaucoup plus vite que les informations vérifiées
qui sont diffusées sur les réseaux sociaux
et par exemple, au début de la pandémie, t'as sûrement vu cette vidéo, une fake news qui a fait des millions de vues.
Elle affirmait que l'Institut Pasteur avait créé le coronavirus
pour vendre des vaccins.
Alors évidemment, c'est faux.
D'ailleurs, pour la petite histoire, l'Institut Pasteur
n'a même pas réussi à faire un vaccin au final.
Et il y a une explication à cette incroyable propagation.
Évidemment, Hugo, tu le sais très bien.
Les fake news ont l'art de mettre notre raisonnement
complètement K.O.
C'est dans le cerveau que ça se passe.
Les scientifiques l'ont montré, il existe des failles
dans notre mode de raisonnement.
C'est ce qu'on appelle les biais cognitifs.
Alors mieux connaître ces biais permet de comprendre pourquoi
on peut se laisser avoir par les fake news.
Et pour voir ça. Eh bien Hugo, je te propose de chausser les gants de boxe et de faire ensemble
une battle fake news / vrai info, les gants sont juste derrière toi.
Parfait.
Allez, c'est parti sur le ring.
Alors si les fake news ont un tel succès, c'est d'abord parce que la plupart du temps, soyons honnêtes,
nous sommes un peu paresseux.
Et puis nous sommes tellement inondés d'informations
que tout vérifié et impossible.
Notre cerveau préfère donc faire
des économies de temps et d'énergie.
Et en plus, les fake news sont développées
et réfléchi justement pour nous appâter,
alors on clique, on partage et on passe à autre chose.
Et donc là, résultat sans appel dès le premier round.,
et bien fake news 1 cerveau 0.
D'une manière générale, en plus, notre cerveau a plutôt la grosse tête.
Ils surestiment l'ampleur de son savoir, ce qui propage volontairement des fake news sont souvent persuadés d'être suffisamment experts
pour pouvoir certifier que les informations sont exactes.
C'est ce que les scientifiques appellent le biais de sur confiance.
Donc la Paresse, surestimation. On est au second round et à ce moment-là, fake News 2 cerveaux toujours à 0 malheureusement.
Allez troisième round et troisième piège.
Mais dans un monde surchargé d'informations comme le nôtre, et bien, ça peut poser quelques problèmes.
On va faire un petit test avec vous. Hugo et moi,
nous allons vous poser une série de questions
et vous allez y répondre le plus rapidement possible.
Prêt Hugo ? Prêt.
Et c'est parti avec la première question du coup,
de quelle couleur est le coton ?
Réponse !
Deuxième question. Quelle est la couleur du papier ?
Maintenant prochaine question, de quelle couleur sont les nuages ?
De quelle couleur est la robe de la mariée ?
Et que boit la vache ?
Et non ! La vache boit de l'eau, pas du lait.
Mais je vous rassure, presque tout le monde
se fait avoir et c'est tout à fait normal.
Les premières informations orientent notre cerveau vers le blanc.
La dernière question le pousse à chercher un liquide lié à la vache.
Et là, Bam, c'est le lait qui tombe.
Vous êtes victime du troisième biais
qui aide les fake news à nous embobiner.
Le biais d'amorçage.
Et là, on comprend mieux pourquoi est ce que
les fake news se propagent aussi facilement,
C'est d'ailleurs intéressant de reprendre l'exemple
du remède miracle au vinaigre contre le coronavirus.
Cette fausse information est écrite de telle manière que notre cerveau va faire un maximum d'association
avec des idées comme celles que l'on vient
d'expérimenter ici avec la vache et le lait.
Par exemple, dans cette fake news, il est écrit que ça vient
de chercheurs américains, de Harvard.
Harvard., on se dit que c'est une prestigieuse université, donc on devrait tendance à avoir plutôt confiance.
Au delà de ça, le vinaigre c'est quelque chose qui peut être utilisé comme un nettoyant,
donc on fait le lien entre tout ça et on peut assez facilement croire que le vinaigre peut permettre de guérir du COVID.
Donc là, clairement ça nous fait fake news 3 cerveau 0.
Dis moi, Jamy, là ça commence
quand même à faire plutôt beaucoup,.
Malheureusement, je crois que c'est pas terminé.
Il existe d'autres biais dans notre cerveau
qui renforce la croyance dans les fake news.
Si on prend aussi en compte le biais de confirmation,
comme l'appellent les chercheurs,
on peut d'ores et déjà affichés fake news 4 cerveau 0.
Notre cerveau a tendance à ne prendre en compte que
les informations qui vont dans le sens de ce qu'il croit déjà.
Si vous êtes déjà convaincu que le vinaigre est un aliment formidable,
et bien vous serez plus facilement amenés à croire à la fake news d'un traitement pour ainsi dire miraculeux de la COVID avec du vinaigre.
Et d'ailleurs, au fond, c'est assez logique.
Si on passait notre temps permanence à remettre en question tout ce que l'on sait parce que on voit une nouvelle information
et bien on serait constamment en train de changer d'avis et en l'occurrence, c'est pas évident.
C'est dire à quel point notre cerveau lutte
contre ce qui ne lui plaît pas.
Et encore plus si cela génère en nous de la peur.
Ouais, le danger, la peur, la catastrophe, c'est des levier très fort sur lesquels s'appuient les fake news.
Et c'est quelque chose qu'on voit au quotidien.
Les fake news jouent souvent sur le sensationnel et en l'occurrence,
c'est là ou c'est particulièrement dangereux.
Et le fait d'avoir peur nous rend plus réceptifs
à d'éventuelles fake news.
Exactement.
Et là, t'as vraiment mis dans le mille.
Un vrai uppercut pour notre système de raisonnement,
car là, on joue directement avec la puissance des émotions
contre laquelle il est beaucoup plus difficile de lutter.
On a besoin de se rassurer sur nous-mêmes,
sur le monde qui nous entoure.
Des chercheurs du MIT,
aux Etats-Unis
l’ont d’ailleurs bien montré.
Ils ont analysé environ
126 000 tweets,
relayant de vraies infos
ou des fake news,
Ou des fake news ?
partagées par à peu près
3 millions de personnes.
3 millions de personnes,
Ils ont alors observé que les vraies informations suscitaient
que les vraies informations suscitait
surtout de l'anticipation,
de la tristesse, de la joie
ou de la confiance,
ou de la confiance.
alors que les fake news entraînaient
Alors que les fêtes news entraînait
de la peur, du dégout
et de la surprise.
Résultat,
Les fake news ont circulé
plus vite et plus largement
plus vite et plus largement,
1% d’entre elles ont touché entre
1 000 et 100 000 personnes
et 100000 personnes,
alors que les vraies infos
ont rarement été partagées
ont rarement été partagé.
à plus de 1 000 personnes.
À plus de 1000 personnes
Lorsque la peur entre en jeu,
le réflexe est de prévenir
le plus de monde possible
du danger potentiel.
possible du danger potentiel.
Malheureusement, sans toujours vérifier si ce danger existe vraiment.
Ouais, clairement, les fake news savent exploiter au mieux nos biais cognitifs pour tromper notre sens de l'analyse
et pour embobiner notre raisonnement.
Moi même je me suis interrogée, avant de citer toutes les fake news qu'on a évoqué.
Après tout, en faisant cette vidéo, on parle une nouvelle fois de ces fausses informations qui ne cherche qu'a se répandre
comme une traînée de poudre et ce même si on s'efforce de démonter leur mécanique et de les dénoncer.
Et bien, elles finissent quand même d'une certaine façon par circuler.
Et tu ne crois pas si bien dire, notre mémoire n'est pas parfaite non plus.
On va avoir tendance à croire plus facilement une information juste parce qu'on l'a déjà vu ou entendu,
même si c'était pour nous expliquer qu'elle n'était pas vrai.
Ce qui rend comme tu le dis, difficile le rétablissement de la vérité.
Le risque : c'est que plus on parle d'une fake news,
plus elle devient familière.
Plus notre cerveau a tendance à la croire facilement.
Bon Hugo, on va pas se laisser mettre K.O sans réagir.
Non, ce serait dommage.
Jamy ce que je te propose maintenant, c'est qu'on fasse un point sur les différents moyens dont on dispose pour réagir
et se protéger face aux fake news.
Nous avons heureusement aussi des ressources pour lutter et nous entrainer à mieux faire le tri parmi les tonnes d'informations
qu'on voit passer tous les jours.
La bonne nouvelle, déjà, c'est que tous les grands médias aujourd'hui se sont penchés sur cette question des fake news et ont mis en place
un service d'enquête, de décodage ou encore de chasse aux infox.
Donc on peut s'appuyer éventuellement dessus et ne pas hésiter
à aller voir leur site, à ouvrir leur page
ou regarder d'ailleurs leurs émissions qui font ce travail nécessaire d'analyse et de vérification des informations.
S'appuyer sur des experts spécialistes de la traque des fake news, le cerveau remporte son premier point.
Deuxième conseil, à la lecture d'une information,
c'est important de se demander qui a écrit cette information.
Qui a filmé, qui a enregistré, dessiné, photographié.
Une information qualifiée, elle émane général d'un auteur
qui s'identifie clairement au début ou à la fin de l'article ou de la vidéo.
Qui est cet auteur ? Est ce que c'est un expert ? Un inconnu ? Quelle est sa légitimité à délivrer cette information ?
Est ce que éventuellement il cite des sources que je pourrais vérifier ?
Quelqu'un qui sort une info et qui dit que ça vient du cousin de sa tante, de son beau-frère, je ne sais quoi.
On va pas se mentir, c'est pas super fiable.
C'est un petit peu comme un plat qu'on vous propose de manger.
Qui l'a cuisiné ?
Interrogez vous, et vous ferez grimper votre score. Nous sommes à 5 pour les fake news et on grimpe à 2 pour le cerveau.
Autre question à se poser, ou est publié l'information ?
Sur quel type de site.
L'éditeur est il un particulier, une entreprise ou encore une association.
Et son site est ce que c'est une vitrine officielle institutionnelle
ou un blog, un réseau social ?
L'objectif du site est-il de vendre ? D'informer ?
De militer ? De faire peur ? De faire le Buzz ?
Autrement dit. Demandez-vous sur quelle assiette ou dans quel bol on vous présente ce que vous devez avaler.
Vous y gagnerez.
Allez, bilan du score.
Fake news 5, 3 pour le cerveau.
On y est presque.
Enfin de quelle nature et l'information qu'on vous propose ?
Est-ce que c'est des faits avec des chiffres,
des lieux qu'on peut vérifier etc.
Ou est ce que c'est une opinion ?
Un avis en fait, sur un sujet d'actualité.
C'est 2 choses, l'information et l'opinion qui sont très importantes
mais c'est aussi de choses qui sont différentes.
L'information est basée sur des faits qu'on peut vérifier etc.
Alors que l'opinion c'est un peu différent. C'est une interprétation des faits, c'est l'image que l'on se fait d'une certaine information.
Bref, questionnez vous sur le plat qu'on vous sert,
histoire de ne pas avaler des salades
et vous éviterez ainsi mieux les intoxications.
Ce qui nous fait fake news. 5 cerveau, 4.
Allez, un dernier petit coup de pouce.
Un petit dernier pour la route.
N'hésitez pas à échanger avec vos amis, votre famille, vos collègues,
de bonnes adresses d'info, de bon contenu d'information, un peu comme on partagerait finalement des bons restaurants.
Pourquoi ne pas essayer de bien
se nourrir aussi en termes de contenu.
Alors évidemment, ça ferait très plaisir vous pouvez partager la chaîne des Épicurieux ou la chaîne HugoDécrypte
mais vous devez aussi pouvoir en trouver d'autres, heureusement.
Il y en a quand même aujourd'hui
beaucoup qui sont disponibles en ligne
Et là, je crois qu'on peut faire avancer le compteur du cerveau.
Passer à 6-5, 7-5, même au-delà.
Effectivement, ça ferait plaisir.
Et toi, Jamy, du coup, est-ce que t'as des astuces personnel
qui pourrait permettre de de compléter tout ça ?
Oui, des habitudes de travail, quand je prépare une vidéo
que je cherche des informations,
je veille toujours à les récolter auprès de différentes sources,
les plus sérieuses possibles.
Par exemple des chercheurs qui travaillent pour des universités,
des revues scientifiques reconnues
ou des pages officielles d'association de gouvernement.
Et c'est particulièrement important sur les sujets que je pense maîtriser
plutôt que de ne me fier qu'a mon intuition ou à ma mémoire,
j'essaie de cultiver le doute, de me remettre en question,
de faire davantage confiance aux experts qu'a mon propre cerveau.
Du coup, en fait, la clé pour éviter la propagation des fake news,
c'est donc de prendre le temps de vérifier l'information
qu'on reçoit avant de la partager.
Surtout d'ailleur, si elle paraît un peu inédite, un peu surprenante comme on a vu là avec la question du vinaigre et du COVID.
Et vous ? Quelles sont vos méthodes pour ne pas tomber
dans le piège des fake news ?
Quand vous êtes-vous fait avoir pour la dernière fois ?
Dites-le nous en commentaire.
Merci beaucoup Hugo pour ses explications et tes conseils.
Merci d'être venu jusqu'ici dans mon atelier
pour aborder ce sujet des fake news
devant mon beau bar.
Bobards, fake news.
Je lai, je lai.
À très bientôt.
Merci !